foreign
Henry's with us in Madison Wisconsin hi
Henry welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave
long time listener thanks for taking my
call certainly sir how can we help
I'm in a bit of a bit I'm in a big mess
and I just wanted to get your advice on
it okay so
um I took FPU about 12 years ago I know
the system I have every dollar Plus
um
I've been engaged to my fiance for about
seven years the only reason that we
haven't gotten married although I
haven't gotten married is I can't afford
to give her her day that she deserves
she wants to wait for that day
um and my concern is is that uh she just
lost her job
due to medical reasons and
um we lost her insurance
she has Cobra but it's 800 a month
there's just absolutely no way that I
can get I can put that 800 line item in
the budget
is it in this situation is it ever
appropriate to take a hardship withdraw
from traditional retirement products so
that you have health insurance
uh do you have health insurance at your
work
I I I'm eligible for health insurance at
my work but I'm a massively serious
connected veteran so the VA takes care
of all my health care
okay so are you taking it let's pretend
a theoretical thing happened and this
was your wife
could you not go to your work and get
spousal insurance through your work
cheaper than eight hundred dollars
I could good but you're getting married
today congratulations on wanting her big
day congratulations toughies sorry
welcome to grown-up girl land
all right seven freaking years
dude that's weird
I understand don't you think it's weird
I think it is a bit to be honest yeah
yeah I've married her five years ago
yeah so you know now she don't have a
choice
her Health's gone and she gets to be
married so that she can get insurance
and we'll call that the special day
and um you guys can have a celebration
because you don't have an 800 a month
Bill I'm seriously this is the um
results of this decision this
weird poor decision to drag something
out seven years has put you guys in this
situation so you've got to fix it I mean
it's the it's the fastest right way to
fix this on so many levels on so many if
Henry if that's real I mean yeah it's
one of those things like is she who you
want to spend the rest of your life with
I'm assuming so because it's been seven
years but is there a hesitation in you
not wanting to fully commit as well
we've been going through a rough patch
and if we were married I would want to
be going to marital counseling but
um
but the finances of what are what has
brought on this really rough patch so
yeah all right we need to get to the
bottom of that first but then yes this
is I mean like this I've had multiple
relationships this is definitely the
woman I want to spend the rest of my
life with okay so if you know that for
sure you're gonna go through hardships
and marriage right or wrong so if she is
it and eventually that's where it's
going to lead then yes I'm with Dave
it's like go get married go y'all y'all
are playing like this you basically are
married without actually the legal
documents so we we have shared finances
everything we've been playing house for
five years yeah so go yeah yeah so go go
get married and then you guys as a
married couple are gonna realize oh wow
we gotta go figure out this money stuff
and get on the same page or you say all
right
sweetie you've got to go get another job
and figure out your health insurance
because no you don't need to take
hardship withdrawal from retirement or
she doesn't either what's wrong with her
health no she would do it um she would
do it diabetes diabetes and morbid
obesity
um she's on we're not sure if she's able
to go back to work at this point
okay
I mean if she's the one Henry
you gotta you gotta yeah
so
um I'm nervous though that the big I
don't know yeah the big day of the
wedding it's like
okay let me let me um take one step back
not 10 steps back but one step back
um
how old are you guys
I'm 34 and she's 31. okay all right
have kids together
uh no no kidding okay
okay
um her
health
is
you you guys need to sit down and see a
you need to spend more than 800 on a
counselor
and you guys need to sit down with a
counselor and you need to dig into
what's going on with her
and uh the special day stuff
um and how is that tied is there any
connection between that and her health
issues
um because I I I'm not a counselor but
I'm smelling a rat and so
um I I would want to get to the bottom
of all of that before I rush off and get
married
um because if she's not gonna and you
get you guys aren't gonna deal with your
issues as a couple and she's not gonna
deal with her issues that are underlying
in all of this then
um
that that's causing these this weird
that's causing this weird situation
there's something she's she's hurting
somewhere and there's something that's
causing this I don't know what that
stuff is I don't have Dr Delaney here to
help me but there's something causing
all this stuff and you don't need to get
married till you figure out what that is
and we're working on it and then you can
figure out the health insurance thing
but the if everything else was
Glory but of course it's not Glory
because we're seven years around waiting
to get off the ladder so um yeah you
need to get to why
these things are going on and if you can
deal with them why then get married and
that'll help her with her health
insurance but no you don't need to have
combined finances you're not married
we don't recommend that I recommend
combined finances for married couples
because it puts you in this weird
situation where you're buying health
insurance for someone that's your
roommate